next one very odd because it's the most
regressive it's unbelievable it's it's
very it's a really strange position to
be a progressive who's reinforcing the
ideologies of a regressive culture
that's very ancient but what's
incredible is that they'll come up with
ways to defend this cognitive
inconsistency and hence that's part of
the ostrich parasitic syndrome that I
was mentioning what are some ways they
defend so example let me just give you a
few manifestations of ostrich logic my
friend Muhammad is a very nice guy and
he drinks and he fornicates and he's
very liberal so the idea then becomes
that as long as I can identify a single
exemplar of a Islamic person who does
not otherwise adhere to what Islam
dictates then it's not true that Islam
is bad now this is this is a
manifestation of a more general
cognitive bias your feedback on so I
would say that George he's saying you
some enough for that because laymen
they're like they can't maybe make out
what we're trying to deduce from here
right what what is in layman's terms
what message are we getting from this
what he's trying to say that anything in
his opinion which complies with his
definition of progression is good its
Lavin does not apply a comply with that
therefore Islam is bad that's his
deduction right he's saying that Islam
is regressive they were aggressive that
means it's in the Stone Age yes in the
Stone Age they said medieval religion
yeah right
so his he's saying he makes his point
quite officer actually says it's very
archaic very medieval very ancient
religion this by the way in logic is
called the genetic fallacy you genetic
fallacy is basically to say and this is
a very it's a textbook informal fallacy
it's one of the first things I don't
learn if they've studied the basics of
logic now he makes this point over and
over again that this is an ancient
religion a very old religion or whatever
I mean so what does that in does that
take away depreciate from its truth
value because actually democracy is more
is more aged than Islam Islam with the
the the big I that which we would say
that the
Mohammed Salim democracy was exercised
in the ancient Greek period of time so
this was a good maybe a thousand years
before Islam or something actually more
than that so we're talking about if that
was the logic your Liberal Democrat was
small Allen small D right you believe in
liberalism and you believe in democracy
yet liberalism or you can say democracy
for sure is an ancient belief and he
makes this point once again so does that
make democracy a unuseful way of life so
once again the genetic fallacy is it
doesn't actually yield any positive
results the second thing is here he's
allowed for his basically I would say
the the ruler by which and through which
he message measures truth the post
enlightenment age which is basically
after there was a philosophical age in a
17-2 in lesson nineteen hundred's
whereby some philosophers came and they
preached certain philosophies of them
liberalism was refined you know lots of
republicanism was was defined refined
lots of popular philosophies were kind
of refined at that period of time and he
thinks the judge of a good society is
that which is complicit with those
particular philosophies my question
would be was the proof for that what's
the evidence for that so you've taken
for granted that the Enlightenment age
is the be-all and end-all is the
pinnacle of human achievement is the
philosophical peak now what is the
objective in an objective way so what is
your way of dealing with that was - what
is your evidence base for that how can
you provide evidence for that in fact if
you look at the Enlightenment period
most of the Philosopher's actually
disagreed with each other on very core
tenants and that's why you had that
conglomerate of different philosophers
always disagreeing with each other each
other on core issues
thus your measure of truth is is really
a subjective measure of truth which
relies only upon I would say the
post-colonial white man's world and this
is very much the way that the
colonialist the British colonialists the
French colonialists the Atari you know
you can say the catalá in colonialist in
the German colonialists all of these
European colonialists the Dutch
colonialists
they actually justified colonizing
glands and that's how America was
actually an innocence formed so if that
is the case my question to you very
directly Joe would be how can you prove
it why how can you prove your your
implicit assumption here that
progression is that which goes towards
Western civilization or its
understanding of enlightenment etc how
can you prove that because you can't
just take those premises for granted
don't we see people judging like Islam
and the civilization of Islam based on
two countries and specifically you have
Afghanistan yeah and Iraq
yeah which have been like blown back
into the Stone Age right so they look at
those places where they've been just
bombed you know and the people who are
living peacefully right and now minding
their own business yeah now we went over
there just turned everything into how
many people died over the innocent
people in Iraq some of the statistics
says one hundred twenty three thousand
hundred twenty-five thousand people died
some say goes up from there the ranging
statistic some say 125 thousand go goes
up to a million so there are ranges in
sickness and that's a massive number
massive yeah that's a massive number
which cannot be compared to anything and
we're not justifying about anything that
the terrorists have done so those
terrorists the Islamic terrorists how
what they have done in terms of human
casualty doesn't compare to just that
one particular war so you blew you blew
up the burned the books and the
libraries you know the ha everything was
just destroyed the country is upside
down so people think okay well this is
Islam they're backward but I mean what I
mean are there some modern days examples
of some countries that Muslims are
living in I mean what what examples do
you give you a Dubai what do you what I
was Lygia where do you what would you
give example us a good question so I
would say generally speaking I wouldn't
I wouldn't say that I wouldn't premise
this by saying that the measure of an
advanced society is necessarily yeah
developmental or economic right but even
if we did look at economic even if we
did think that as a as a as a kind of
measure there are some cities and some
countries now in the Muslim world like
in Malaysia like in Indonesia like in
Turkey like in different countries like
I do you say UAE these are countries
which
growing up a rapid rate however who
cares it doesn't do anything to prove
reduce increase the truth value of Islam
or any other religion look at where
America was a good hundred years ago
there was there there was the Wall
Street Crash in the Great Depression
this was literally a hundred years ago I
mean we're talking about the 1920s and
thirties the Wall Street Crash in the
Great Depression does that mean that the
values that you take so so much for
granted were false then and they're true
now there's economic growth and
sustainability necessitate truth I think
this is actually something that a lot of
people do believe that if something if
the values of a particular country are
good then the economics would be good
and that's something he said in another
segment or one of his guests today it's
a very false kind of fallacious type of
logic China should be at the forefront
of our analysis then whatever they
believe it must be the truth because
according to many different economists
they're saying that China were actually
overtake America and its overall GDP and
and will overtake it even militarily in
100 years or 50 years
one more point what about when Islam was
at it's what they call Golden Age yeah
when you look at Islam was now in Spain
in places like this right how advanced
how they sit progressive was a
regressive back then or was the
resolution was to the rest of the world
we're people in the Dark Ages
what happened if you use this example
well that's a really good question
because I would I would argue that if
you look at for example the time period
of about 410 AD to 1485 AD this is what
is commonly referred to as the Middle
Ages yeah the Middle Ages is also
referred to ironic ly as the European
Dark Ages and the reason why they call
it that is literally because the
Europeans didn't have at that particular
time much of a cultural economic or
philosophical contribution on the world
and in fact the superpowers of the world
were not the Western world after
fourteen eighty five there was a massive
shift because basically the Europeans
found the Americans and that was the age
of discovery and the Renaissance also
started the early modern period side
there's lots of different things outside
at the same time but if you think about
the period of time that I've just
mentioned the abetted Empire for example
was seen as the strongest he
Empire in the world and so if we use
this the same logic we have to look at
the historical timeline he's one of his
arguments one of the arguments as
panelists often time make is that
economic growth is a measure of truth
well if that's the case we have to look
at all of the time and this is a false
promise anyways but you look at all the
time and the Quran actually informs us
of the fact that there will be days and
there were times where non-muslims would
be will be successful whether it be
militarily economically and Muslims will
be successful economically militarily
well in his loss upon title when he says
what till kill a yam no there will have
been a Baroness these are the days which
we alternate between the people yes so
in other words there'll be some days
which will be prosperous and victorious
and other days which you'll be which you
will not be prosperous and victorious
yeah all right let's go to the next one
you